vuelven a sanar libres detenidos durante
años por el gobierno respaldado por
Arabia Saudita estos antiguos
prisioneros luchaban con Los rebeldes
sutiles apoyados por Irán
Al otro lado del asfalto las familias
destrozadas por la guerra esperan con
impaciencia el regreso de sus seres
queridos
llevamos mucho tiempo esperando este
momento lo he extrañado tanto que estoy
deseando volver a verlo
al mismo tiempo miembros del gobierno y
de la coalición militar liderada por
Arabia Saudita llegaban a adén estaban
siendo retenidos por los útiles entre
ellos el exministro de defensa mahamut
al subaijí coordinado por el comité
Internacional de la Cruz Roja este
intercambio Está programado para durar
tres días participan cerca de 900
prisioneros su Liberación se produce
tras el acuerdo alcanzado a finales de
marzo en Suiza entre el gobierno
reconocido por la comunidad
internacional y Los Rebeldes un acuerdo
firmado tras el inesperado acercamiento
entre Arabia Saudita e Irán los grandes
rivales que chocan a veces en bandos
Opuestos como en yemen
esta semana una delegación Saudita fue
asaná Se marchó el jueves con un acuerdo
preliminar sobre una tregua y la promesa
de nuevas conversaciones
Esto hace albergar esperanzas de que se
calme la situación en este país donde la
guerra ha provocado una de las peores
crisis humanitarias del mundo con
cientos de miles de muertos y millones
de desplazados